we we have a society of that's going
back to earth worshiping and child
sacrifices
yep well actually i disagree which
brings me to the next story we have
from interactive polls on twitter
generic congressional ballot trends
before versus after roe v wade decision
take a look at this republicans and
democrats in june 21 it was republican
plus four
on june 27 it was republican plus five
republicans gained one point after
scotus overturned roe v that's
technically not true
democrats lost a point after the roe v
wade decision interesting so that is
interesting
why is it the republicans were like i'm
cool with that and democrats were like
we're mad at democrats over this
that's that's the progressive left
pulling the the centrist uh moderate
democrats over in the left field i saw
that a lot i didn't i didn't realize
until i started watching well i didn't
start watching you know per se but i
watched the young turks about a month
ago and the whole roe v wade thing was
was first breaking out when the document
got leaked and anna caspet was her name
yeah yeah yeah me and her got into a
huge twitter back and forth and and when
i watched it i realized that the left
pundits were talking less about
republicans or trumpers and they were
talking more about
the uh the the this you know contentment
they had with joe biden and the
establishment democrats and that's just
a way for them to to pull them over into
into left field and i think when i watch
joe biden talk now i can see that he's
not so much speaking against the right
as he's trying to appease the far left
yeah yeah well joe biden is weird right
because for so long he's adopted these
far left positions and he said things
about how we need to like affirm
children which is just another way of
saying that you should be able to push
them through gender transitions that
kind of thing um he's also extremely
radically pro-abortion he wants to
repeal the hyde amendment which prevents
federal funding from uh from going
towards abortions and then
when the polling data starts to make it
clear that these positions are unpopular
he comes out at the state of the union
and says
defund the police no man i got to defend
the police and talking about how we need
to secure the border and basically
taking trump's platform yeah so the man
he doesn't stand for anything right
chameleon that's why he falls for
everything exactly like falling through
the stairs
off of a bike that wasn't moving well
his foot got caught in the in the clip
he tripped so i'll give him that one you
trip easier when you're at that age yeah
yeah i just what happened with the bike
is that he has his pedal clips
and when he stopped
he tried he took his left foot out and
then he leaned right as he was trying to
pull his right foot out but he didn't
get it out and so he fell over
i it's it happens to people it's more
likely to happen to if you're old but it
wasn't like he was just standing there
and just fell down right you know what i
mean right yeah i just think i i think
i'd like to see a little more
proficiency in bicycle riding from the
man leading the free world and walking
upstairs yeah well i supposedly never
forget how to ride a bike but i guess
dementia is another story so look like
brutal i think it's fair to say the dude
fell down but i want to point out his
foot got stuck in a bike
american military
man it's not it's not about the point
that was worse it's not like he was
riding his bike and then just went
and fell over no no he was standing
that's also why people are joking about
it because he was like standing still
when he fell over yeah he should have
leaned on his left foot and pulled his
right foot out or had some some sort of
cognizance to not lean into it as he
started to fall but he didn't have his
card that said you please hold your left
foot out
royce that the democratic party is kind
of turning on itself uh and you see that
in the colbert interview like they've
just completely dismissed joe biden and
kamala harris they're not even mentioned
of those people they've agreed they're
useless they're not gonna run in 2024.
it's hilarious it is go ahead no it says
biden they're they're all sitting around
a table and they're like so who's
running in 2024 and biden goes oh i'm
going to run for re-election and they go
yeah yeah so what does it run yeah 2024
he's just sitting there like he's not in
the room you know what i mean yeah i i
think these two were always the cutouts
i think light and combat yeah i think
they were always transitory cutouts from
the beginning sacrificial yeah
candidates
i mean if you just look at their records
look at how easy it would be to
dislike them over the course of their
administration it's almost like the
democratic party is casting upon joe
biden all of their sins so they can have
the slaves
sacrifice as a candidate and they can
bring someone else in to fix the problem
why would that be far-fetched for people
like this is what troubles me and we
talked about this a little bit last time
do we think that george soros or klaus
schwab or these international governing
bodies and and these uh eclectic
metropoli
metropolitan omnisexuals don't think
four
years and eight years ahead
like is that really tough for us to
graft it is because most people live in
this sort of radical materialist
everyday lifestyle where they do eat
these fatty foods and they do play on
their video games and they do you know
get the the immediate instant
gratification from their social media
likes or whatever
so it's hard for them to imagine a group
of people who are effective and thinking
that far ahead because they don't do it
but these people have proved that they
are willing to do it and they're very
effective at doing it i think that joe
biden was always a cut out
from the very beginning i think that's
why they uh undermined bernie in the in
the in the uh democratic uh election
when when joe bide ran i think when he
resigned from the in 1988 when he was
running against george bush senior and
resigned because he was found out to be
a plagiarist is the entire industry gave
up on him and basically turned him into
a cardboard cutout like they realized
he's nothing more than a cutout at this
point maybe we'll use him at some point
he came out 2008 to run against obama
they put him up there as like the token
old white businessman and then yeah he
was the establishment guy right because
obama was too new and radical at least
in his rhetoric at least that's why
people don't like aoc yeah just like
yeah exactly but obama right he was like
the fringe radical anti-establishment
guy and people were worried and so he
goes with the most pro-establishment
cardboard cutout that he could find i
i do want to point out i pull up the
real clear politics average of polls
because that one poll was was i think
that was just iowa right
so in the real quick politics average
after the ruling republicans went up
about a half point democrats actually
made a fairly decent gain in aggregate
they went from 41.3 to four so they went
up one point republicans went up a half
point republicans made a gain on this
one democrats made it again in this one
but republi so democrats closed the gap
a little bit republicans still have a
2.5 uh point advantage in the generic
ballot which
is just apocalyptic well we're when
democrats are leading by five points
they lose seats so anything short of a
five point advantage from democrats
that's break even right now it's it's
just every day looking apocalyptic for
democracy
things have changed so much about who's
a democrat and who's a republican now
that it's the people that like care
enough to virtue signal that they will
fill out one of these polls they tend to
be democrats in the past it's now but
it's an aggregate poll so so this is
combining all the different polls
so that's what's interesting about this
i don't i don't take just a single poll
where like fox news has to ask somebody
no this is hugo politico npr pbs
trafalgar rasmussen usa today fox news
and quinnipiac all of those different
polls with different methodologies and
they average it out that's your best
indicator but did they include real
patriot polls from
realpatriot.blogspot.com
real patriot dot
infowarrior.website.website
and it's like 97 say donald trump is the
best three percent say donald trump is
pretty good
i got i got an email from trump and i'm
i bet most of you have gotten this too
and it was like please fill out this
poll how well do you think donald trump
is doing really like it's that he's
doing fantastic he's doing great he's
doing pretty good he's doing all right
and i'm like it's only positive
the only options were like he's doing
good in some way gotta love it yeah i
know that's trump man yeah that's a
trumpet my fear right now in politics is
that again to reiterate the ability for
people to look ahead the establishment
to look ahead that a lot of these
republicans are not really republicans
or they're not really conservatives i
think that a lot of the republic i think
it's
it's understood that the political the
politics in america are going to go in
ebbs and flows
and that right now the republicans are
on the rise
and they're going to
do everything they can within the
republican establishment to put people
forward who may even say that they're
america first
but really aren't
uh and i'm seeing that in my own primary
but i see it as i look even across some
of the people that joke that donald
trump endorsed like oz right these
people these people don't really
fundamentally understand the ideas of
america or the foundational values of
america
and and if they come to power even if
it's a republican-held uh you know house
senate
presidency uh america could still be on
a losing track with republicans in
office because the the republicans have
been in on it oh yeah well we we sort of
joked about this a while ago when we
were first going through this this
polling data
which suggests that there will likely be
russian interference but when we were
looking through this polling data i was
just kind of joking about the fact that
yeah i know the republicans uh might win
in a landslide so they can not do
anything they can just keep not doing
anything sit on their hands and just say
slow down there come on you're going too
far to be fair though you know i do rag
on mitch mcconnell he did basically yeah
get this roe v wade thing it's true we
were talking about that with will my my
issue though is like partly the reason i
was thinking about this like you know
i'm still ragging on mitch for
republicans he actually he actually got
this for them for me that wasn't a big
issue for me the issue was like you know
i'm i'm more libertarian i'm not
conservative so for me roe v wade i'm
rather dispassionate on it goes back to
the states i'm kind of like okay that's
federal government rescinding authority
that there's probably a lot of good
things in that my answer to democrats on
the left is they should be filing
lawsuits at the state level i'm on the
same grounds at the federal level and
then win in the states
what i want to see is republicans win on
policy grounds that they just don't
engage on they don't they haven't
engaged at all on the social media
censorship they just spin around in
circles they're caving on gun rights for
me i just don't see anything auditing
the federal reserve i mean i'll take it
let the economy flounder like this
that's that's the ultimate failure of a
politician right now is to let the
economy fly so you're saying that you
think
because the roe v wade issue
is well the roe v wade issue was
illegitimate in its inception that's
number one so for mitch mcconnell to
back this
isn't necessarily as extreme as it
as it seems
due to the public you know the public's
view of it now but constitutionally it's
not really an extreme position
as say him being more america first on
trade or other policies mitch mcconnell
played the judge game and republicans
played the judge game and ignored the
cultural issues the cultural issues have
a big impact on me so i'm biased
for conservatives who are pro-life they
they they were ragging on mitch
mcconnell and republican leadership over
the culture war issues but then when
they get this victory on roe v wade
they're like oh okay what they did
worked for us for me roe v wade wasn't
one of my issues so i'm like gun rights
free speech you know uh schools and all
that stuff what are you doing on these
issues that i'm worried about so i
acknowledge that's my bias mitch
mcconnell was very effective in getting
the roe v wade decision for
conservatives that's a fact yeah for the
recent gun decision too right the racing
gun decision absolutely it's a fair
point yeah it makes it through the
courts it doesn't go as far as uh i'd
like it to but i'm like okay those are
those are decent victories i do think
and and so credit where credit is due as
much as i'm still not a big fan of the
republicans because policy wise they do
very little the judges did get some
victories but if the republicans aren't
adequately engaged in cultural issues
and if the republican leadership won't
go after joe biden they won't go after
the corruption then like that's that's
that's where i'm you know very concerned
like congratulations you won in the
courts you know pro-lifers got their
thing pro-gun people got got their thing
what about joe biden being corrupt what
about the corruption from the
establishment after donald trump why
didn't the republicans do more to to to
stop what was happening in in this
system
i i focus on that there is that they're
in on it oh yeah yeah they're in on it
that's why oh i mean you look at
pennsylvania the the republican establi
you look at robbie starbuck the
republican establishment does not like
trump maga and the populist republicans
and they want they're they're okay
within it the the two sides of the coin
is that the left has traded the and this
is the this is a problem for most
american people but you can see it very
well in the political dichotomy the left
has traded their freedom for materialism
and the right or the republicans have
traded their freedom for security both
versions are an expansion of government
most people have become okay with the
idea that their american citizenship
depends on the expansion of government
and mitch mcconnell is all for the
expansion of government this is the
funny thing when uh when aoc and pelosi
say that the supreme court's extremist
or illegitimate and i see these memes
where they're like the supreme court has
stripped the rights away and i'm like
actu actually they didn't the supreme
court said the federal government
doesn't have this authority it's
actually anti-fascism like if you claim
your antifa
and you don't like authoritarianism and
all that stuff the federal government
being like we hereby rescind this power
should be a good thing but oh no that
meant states now have have control over
these situations and they don't like
what actual decentralization means
what so when these anti-food left people
and leftists come up and they're saying
things like
we shouldn't have these authoritarian
systems
they're actually saying we should
because if you were to get rid of the
federal government and decentralize
everything then all of a sudden smaller
jurisdictions take take authority in how
they want to run things and all of a
sudden you'll find
when you get rid of the centralized
authority you're going to see white-only
towns you're going to see anti-lgbtq
towns you're going to see no more roe v
wade in red states what they really are
saying is they want the federal
government to enforce their
ideology everywhere their own politics
that's right that's exactly right well
and when you look at the uh the
democratic party platform
and what they're pushing for with
respect to abortion i don't think it's
unfair to say that the actual party
platform more or less suggests that
for any child
any unborn child in any part of the
country to have any kind of legal
protection as a travesty for there to be
any unborn child anywhere in the country
that can't be killed is a miscarriage of
justice from their perspective it's evil
it's just evil it's it's it's just i'm
sorry man it's just so weird
and it's it's rooted i i can only say
it's written in ignorance
people in blue states are unaffected by
the roe v wade decision in fact the
decision likely will cause democratic
politicians to expand abortion access in
blue states
so that what they're basically saying is
people in places where i don't live
should be allowed to get access to a
procedure most of those people don't
want exactly because again for whatever
reason
any innocent faultless unborn child
having any legal protection is abhorrent
to them they can't stand it they can't
tolerate it so
here's the problem with the republicans
we talked about mitch mcconnell he got
some some major policy victories um and
the republican leadership did and i'll
tell you uh
the one of the issues is i've totally
lost my train of thought what were you
talking about
roe v wade
yeah i lost wasn't gonna say i forgot oh
that's because i keep thinking yeah well
i think i was gonna i was gonna say that
this this roe v wade one is not even a
judgment call in my book agreed the
morality of it is very clear okay i
remember what i was gonna say go i got
it back i got it back because i'm
reading i'm like reading these polls
okay i forgot again go ahead
i'm getting out bro
we were talking about the success of the
republicans republicans are are running
on moderate policy mitch mcconnell may
have got a victory but i think this
should i should make this statement the
fact that you sheamus think it was a
victory that half the country is allowed
to murder babies shows the problem i
don't think that that's a vic i think
it's a i do think it's a victory in a
step in the right direction but it is
absolutely not going far enough it's not
right it's not murder it is yeah okay
okay hold on legion that's not illegal
my point is if conservatives do believe
that regardless of your opinion ian
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you